We should break up.
There's gotta be something I can say,
I'm gonna go
But I'm not giving up
There you are man! You're lucky I found ya I was worried about ya.
Found me? No, I called you.
You've been gone for like a week.
Nothing focuses your mind like a broken heart.
It could have been different. Let me rephrase
It's gonna be different
Please don't tell me you think this is what I think you think this is
It's a time machine
I have created what every broken heart wants
A second chance
I think you're the best.
That's very sweet of you...?
Stillman
Stillman,
We really did travel through time.
We could go anywhere. Do anything!
We're here to get Debbie back.
Okay, then How about I get to fix my crap year a little?
What do you have in mind?
What the hell are you wearing?
Rogaine. I have this stuff all last year and could never decide if I needed it,
We both know how that turns out
Evan, we'll take the stairs
Ah my foot
AH
AHHHH!!!
That was an amazing game
I won it for you.
Really?
Nah that was a dumb thing to say
hi
Did you like it?
Stay with me here in this perfectly imperfect moment
lol bye
You have made so much progress
You'll probably get back together once we're home!
AHH
You broke our time machine?
No, I can get it to move forward and that's it.
I gotta get everything right the first time around
second time around
whatever
AHHHHHH
I can't believe you just did that!
I don't want this to end
I'm getting us out of here
in 25 seconds.
So, I was gonna check out my new shower
Ok
Wanna join me?
Wait no, no no, no, no  wait wait wait